hey guys I wanted to do a video on the
10 triggers of inflammation now here's
the problem with inflammation number 1
cancer tends to travel and migrate to
areas of inflammation ok so that's
number one and also if you're in this
inflammatory State you have this immune
reaction going on with histamines too
much histamine in the body is basically
a fatigue poison it's going to make you
tired so you're gonna have mucus you're
gonna have congestion and you're gonna
be tired ok so there's all sorts of
things that you can do to reduce
inflammation but first we have to
identify the triggers so let's kind of
cover all the different triggers number
one food allergies that's the most
obvious when you eat something you're
allergic to you become inflamed usually
in the gut in the intestines could be
the small intestine or large intestine
certain parts of your body could be
allergic to certain things but not other
parts pretty interesting right so let's
say in your small intestine in the lower
part and you can have an allergy to
gluten and that can create an ulcer or
an irritation or even this inflammatory
condition so you have anything like
colitis diverticulitis anything itis is
inflammation so the classic thing is
dairy and then nuts like peanuts those
are the most common things that people
are allergic to that basically create
just way too much inflammation ok
insulin resistance when you have this
condition you're going to have higher
amounts of inflammation you're going to
be stiff you're gonna have pain in your
body in your joints and of course this
comes from sugar so sugar is highly
inflammatory so of course we're not just
talking about sugar we're talking about
all the hidden sugars in the juice and
the bread and the pasta and cereal and
the sweetener all that can potentially
cause a lot of inflammation and the
reason I'm bringing this up is this just
the most common reason why people are
inflamed and then soon as they change
your diet the inflammation goes away I
personally in my 20s had serious
inflammation of all the joints in the
back of the hands and I had this
condition right here that's why I had
inflammation and I was trying all these
different remedies but it wasn't working
because I didn't get
basic eating implemented at all so you
have to fix that next one cortisol is
normally in an anti-inflammatory hormone
now cortisol is an adrenal hormone it's
produced by the outer portion of the
adrenals and it's supposed to in theory
get rid of inflammation but when you
actually have lower amounts of cortisol
let's say you of cortisol resistance and
you have the situation where it's low in
certain parts but high in others or you
run out of course all because you have
adrenal fatigue you can develop
inflammatory conditions big time there's
a condition called Addison's which is a
very low adrenal the adrenal burnout
where the person has inflammation
everyone in their bodies John F Kennedy
had that and you have to take a steroid
what's a steroid like prednisone it's
basically cortisol it's a synthetic
version of that so any condition that
involves taking cortisone cream cortisol
injections prednisone is really an
adrenal weakness so there's so many
inflammatory conditions from autoimmune
diseases to skin problems to poison ivy
to our thright Asst that basically is
involving low cortisol so if you have
this condition I put links down below
for all these conditions but if you have
this condition you want to strengthen
the adrenal okay a licorice by the way
is a good thing to take as a natural
cortisol replacement not the candy
licorice but licorice extract but
there's definitely a huge connection
between cortisol and inflammatory
conditions all right now the next one is
old injuries if you have an old injury
whether it's a sprained ankle a fall in
the tailbone breaking a bone like I have
I pretty much you know injured a lot of
different parts of my body over the
years and it comes back to haunt you you
have these low-grade stiffness
inflammation going on in the joint
because it's been damaged and there's
not a lot of circulation in there
I have a lot of videos on what to do and
how to address this but if you do in a
minute fasting you can greatly reduce
the inflammation even from old injuries
okay so this is a really important thing
to talk about and people they don't they
think that it's in the past it's fine
but there's a huge connection the
inflammation will stay there infection
okay so you you're gonna have
inflammation because it's part of the
immune system the body is starting to
attack certain things so a lot of people
have yeast or Candida or viruses in
certain parts of the body bacterial
infections and overgrowth of unfriendly
bacteria Lyme so there's all these
different infections that can occur in
the body even from like a tooth that is
damaged that then leaks bacteria into
the system even into the heart it can
settle in there so you can develop all
sorts of inflammatory conditions in
different parts of the body there's even
a very small microbe called a nano
bacteria that seems to use a calcium
igloo or a shell to protect itself and
so it's really hard to kill this microbe
because it's protected they're very
stealth so you'll be small bacteria the
called nano bacteria that create this
infection in the body and create more
inflammation and more problems in your
kidney and the heart tartar and the
teeth that's really an infection going
on so there's things to deal with that
as well one remedy to dissolve the shell
to decalcify the shell would be
something called EDTA the key later
tolls a show-off but then you would want
to take a natural antibiotic so anytime
someone has this connection to
inflammation I always recommend herbal
antibiotics clove is a really good one
oregano is great
thyme is wonderful you can even take
garlic but it's actually really
important to start clearing out the old
infection the body and of course you
want to avoid the sugar that feeds it
okay but infection is actually very very
common but it's kind of a low-grade
infection it's not really showing up as
a as a major thing but it's hiding it's
a hidden infection and the big thing
that you're going to notice is fatigue
you're gonna have to take okay oxidants
now this could be many things from too
much sugar to junk food alcohol but I
want to mention free iron okay free iron
is very corrosive it's very oxidative in
the body
it destroys things it goes to the brain
and destroys and oxidized
the brain it oxidizes the arteries and
basically creates like a rusting effect
and then the body comes in and to repair
it with calcium and cholesterol so
that's called plaque okay it happens in
the brain happens in the heart it could
happen other places but oxidants can
create an inflammatory condition because
there's an immune reaction going on and
by the way microbes both good and bad
eat iron and so when you're actually you
start developing inflammation the body
starts to hide and pull the iron out in
for itself so so as a survival mechanism
so the pathogens the bad bacteria can't
eat it so you have this you could have
this sudden drop of iron and call it a
cause even anemia from that the point is
that anytime you have too much iron
you're gonna have more infection and
more oxidants and more problems okay how
would you be exposed to iron the number
one way would be through a supplement
there's all these like very low-grade
low quality supplements out there that
are iron supplements that you're getting
this the wrong kind of iron you want to
get your iron from grass-fed like you do
liver extract you can get it in the pill
or grass-fed spleen extract okay that's
even better you'll have enough iron it's
gonna be wonderful
it's it's bound to a protein it's not
like this free iron is called elemental
ion you want to stay away from that
that's in the most popular synthetic
vitamins I don't recommend that also in
wheat products they enrich the wheat
with iron well you're gonna feel it's
going to be very heavy in your gut when
you consume that in Europe they don't
use that like an Italy they will not use
that
only in America welcome to America but
iron is very very corrosive it's very
bad it can create a lot of problems in
the body
okay so alcohol that's a given and also
junk food will create more damage to the
body and create inflammation so again
that was my problem I was living in junk
food and drinking alcohol and wondering
why I was inflamed when the liver is
damaged you're gonna have a lot of
inflammation okay omega 6 fatty acids
soy and corn oil highly inflammatory
it's GMO it's going to create
inflammation so you just don't want to
consume
these oils raw nuts and raw seeds have
enzyme inhibitors they they tend to
create a problem with your digestion
especially in the gallbladder so when
you consume too many nuts especially
they're not germinated or soaked in
water overnight and cleaned up and dried
out then you're gonna have more
irritation and inflammation in the body
so for some people okay not everyone but
that can be a problem now the reason I
wanted to add this in there the gall
bladder is because this isn't something
you're not gonna find a lot of research
on it's just something I personally
observed working with a lot of people
like thousands tens of thousands of
people over 30 years a lot of times they
have a gall bladder that is congested
you know from various reasons maybe
they're eating junk food or too much
sugar but the gall bladder swells up it
gets congested it becomes deficient in
bile and they get bloating an
inflammatory condition in the gut so
their stomach becomes inflamed from that
when they eat okay you can also have
high problems with cortisol and get
inflammation the gut as well especially
if it's like your stomach is flat in the
morning yet at night it gets bigger but
the point is that not only will the gall
bladder problem cause swelling and
inflammation in your digestive tract and
over the gallbladder itself but it's
going to refer pain to the right neck
and shoulder and shoulder blade anything
through this side that's inflamed it's
from the gallbladder it's a very very
common so the way you would know that is
you'd press there Neath the right
ribcage massage this area for two
minutes I am gone now you know you need
to do something to help this condition
probably change your diet that might
help you alright so I just wanted to
kind of give you a summary of all the
different connecting connecting dots
with inflammation hope that helped and
make a little note down below and tell
me what you thought about this video
thanks for watching
hey guys so there's a whole bunch of
people that really need this information
so press the share button and let's get
it way out there